hey guys it's justine and today i'm
doing a really fun collab
of course it's a virtual one because
2020. but this is so much fun i'm doing
a collab with joshua john russell who is
an incredible
baker he makes the most artistic cakes
that i have
ever seen we've done some collabs before
in the past but today
it's gonna be a very different one so
i'm basically just kind of sitting
around
waiting for him to facetime me they
mailed me a big box of stuff that i
don't even know what's inside of it so
we're gonna
chat open it up together and then we're
gonna
make a cake oh my gosh how are you i'm
doing well how are you
hello from the east coast i'm actually
doing pretty good that's good can you
believe it it's been
wait how many years has it been since we
made a video i was thinking the nintendo
switch cake when you were actually at my
house
oh that's right but then you came to my
house i did look at my new studio oh my
gosh it's so
nice isn't it cool wow mine is uh
well still the same okay are we ready
are we doing it i think so yeah let me
i'm gonna set you right here by my ipad
well i don't have any oh i'll get a
little cake stand here we go i'll put
you on a little cake stand
look at this this is cool whoa
but i mean come on now that's the one i
love that knife all right i'm gonna
start pulling things out because i see
boxes
i'm still cutting
it should be the same stuff in each box
i'm not tall enough to reach in my box
she's struggling what's in here it feels
cold so it looks like little shoes like
a little shoe box
oh it is cake i got nervous for a second
oh my gosh
it is cake oh this looks so good so can
i eat these or
yes they're edible so brandon says
okay what's this skinny box i don't know
let's do it i'm scared
it's really light it is really light
what is it oh my god this is the justine
box
dude these are like two of my favorite
things
you made a cake for me with doritos and
butterfinger and i still haven't made
one i've never made a doritos cake but i
told justine that i would make one
after she made one for me it looks like
i've got some icing
i got icing too and i've got
what is this it looks like chocolate oh
that's not what i was gonna say
why do i have no knives and i'm on the
phone with justine and i don't have a
knife over here you really should i mean
come on oh this is mirror glaze it kind
of i it looks like
it looks like potty
oh you fell you fell when you open it
you'll it smells like um
like chocolate syrup all right is that
it what else do we have i also have some
sprinkles
i got sprinkles too mine say that
they're luxury they are
you should taste them though because
they actually have like white chocolate
crispies in them and they taste really
good
no way this is so super fancy
all right i got one more thing in here
gold balls
oh these are like gold crispies i use
these these are really pretty
okay how are you feeling are you feeling
good about all this are you intimidated
are you scared
are there any rules okay so we have to
use a little bit of each of these
at least a little but then you can add
whatever you want oh
so here's the thing i haven't done any
baking videos in a very long time so i
have
basically nothing but sprinkles anything
else that i have has probably
expired so thankfully i've got this this
feels like enough
blind box challenge we're gonna nail it
i already know what i'm doing like it's
already in my head
i'm so scared okay i'm ready
one two three team
this is gonna be such a challenge
because i have not
done any type of baking in this kitchen
in a very long time i just went through
and i had to get rid of a lot of my
baking supplies because they were all
expired so i don't even know
what i have to make this cake happen i
basically have
what i have in front of me and that's
pretty much it
[Music]
okay
one cake two kick
it's the ipad's 10th birthday this year
so i thought that maybe i could make
a birthday cake for the ipad but i gotta
figure out how
to use all of these things you know what
i can do
i can blend them all together and put it
on the inside kind of like how dairy
queen puts like the crunchy
little oreo cookies in the middle tyler
has a look of disgust on his face right
now
i think it's good look sweet salty
sweet salty
[Music]
i don't know what i'm gonna do
okay i'm gonna make a birthday cake
for the ipad
[Music]
we are going to mix doritos and
butterfinger together
oh my god i love doritos so much
butterfinger
when you are a professional chef like me
or a baker
that's the end of the sentence i think
that we should also put some balls in
here too
these are luxury
oh does that smell good
[Music]
okay pulse
i know i know it's brilliant you don't
even have to say
anything
i think that smells nice
i need to taste my creation
i'm a genius put that fork in there have
a bite of that
tell me what you think
[Music]
if you didn't know why is that good i
know so we have that i'm gonna put that
as a filler
inside each layer
[Music]
it looks so good
all right i think that's nice that's
pretty good yeah let's probably
just sprinkle that on there
that's nice i think i might put whole
butterfinger
bars in the middle we're going to do
that
[Music]
i wonder if there's going to be voting
like we're going to vote on who wins the
competition
is it a competition i mean it's like a
challenge
but is this like a 2020 challenge where
you know everybody wins looks good to me
[Music]
i'm dancing to royalty-free music in my
head
birthday to the ipad
happy birthday to the ipad
do we want to color the icing
because i mean a colorful icing might be
pretty
let's see what we have up here
oh we have every single color imaginable
[Music]
okay i could be here all freaking day so
we should probably stop because
we're on a time limit here
this actually looks good
[Music]
i have some ideas oh i think i have like
some gold
powder ah yes we do freaking
come on man
[Music]
i feel like so who was the doctor that
made frankenstein
the doctor's name is frankenstein wait
but then didn't he make a monster
yeah but then he named it after himself
frankenstein's monster yeah but it's not
the monsters
really i feel like my entire life
everything that i knew is no more
what is frankenstein's monster's name i
can't get the answer
freaking surprise i think i'm done wow
this really took a turn for the worse
[Laughter]
so now i'm gonna call joshua back and we
will compare cakes
and see what he came up with he's
definitely i don't think he's gonna be
able to top this
i mean look at this beautiful art
maybe i should clean up first i don't
want him to see my kitchen like what
i've done to it
i guess he will see because he's gonna
watch the video hello friend
hi how was your day you're not crying
your house is not on fire
you don't have mess like uh butter came
all over you so it looks like
you did okay um i've cleaned up you
don't even know
what this place looked like and i also
have a robot vacuum
that did most of the cleaning for me i
can't wait to see the footage though
so do you want to show me your cake
first or like do we do like a reveal at
the same time
i should go first so i can set the bar
super low
come on let me see so it's the ipad's
10th anniversary this year so i made a a
birthday cake
for the ipad i love that okay i'm gonna
put you down
oh there okay justine okay don't get
so you when if you get close up i'm so
proud that looks really good
it looks better than i thought there's a
little ten i see the sprinkles
oh that's so nice so you guys just
crushed uh what did you put
what's the sandy looking stuff the
topping so you know how i like to use a
blender
i blended doritos the gold balls
the butter finger the sprinkles it is
all in here
oh my god that's gonna be so awesome so
i
just did what i felt like doing i i
wanted to do something that would make
you smile
um you totally like branded yours and
made like a story out of it i don't have
a story
i just made a fun cake so here it is you
ready
oh shut up what oh my god
i decided to go rainbow and of course i
added a tear because you know i'm me and
i'm super extra
look i made gold doritos that's such an
incredible idea oh my god
i dipped them in chocolate so they stick
they'll stay uh crunchy and not get
soggy and then i painted them gold
that is such a good idea wait okay so
how did you
how did you do how did you make it so
tall well i took the four cakes and i
cut them all in half
so that's eight layers you'll see when i
cut it and inside it's all rainbow
what that's incredible oh my gosh well i
just put
full on butterfinger slices in here
i love that so much okay here we go
let's do it all
knife her knife is so aggressive
i love it so much wow i just cut through
the layer of butterfinger oh it's gonna
look so cool
i didn't know like that glaze stuff i
used that in the middle to stick my
cakes together
hey you know what you were creative with
it here we go
boom rainbow look how nice that is
you're so talented rainbowy
wow okay so let me show you inside here
this layer here is doritos
okay this one is full butterfinger
chunks
and this one is the mixture of the uh
little dust
that i made that looks delicious for
sure
yay a successful blind box challenge
right
this is the first one and we both made
cool cakes i'm super excited
i mean this turned out way better than i
thought i was gonna try to figure out a
way to put the ipad inside of it
but then i was worried i might ruin my
ipad so i didn't do it
it looks so good though i'm super proud
of you that's awesome yours is so
good though that looks incredible i'm
very important well i had to make
i had to do something that would make
you smile uh hopefully soon we can do
this in person because i want you to
come to my new studio
i know i want to check it out it's
awesome thanks girl all right thanks bye
thank you guys so much for watching this
was so much fun joshua is so incredibly
talented
and i've been such a huge fan of his for
so long and he just started a new show
called you've been deserted i'll put a
link in the description if you want to
watch him make his incredible cake and a
ton of other amazing videos
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
and to joshua's
and i will think about how to improve
my baking next time
[Music]
you